did you travel Europe a lot was like a
kid with your family because oh oh I did
I did my parents we did oh okay it was
okay yeah I don't know much but a lot of
the places I'm like I don't remember
anything like I went to Malta and I'm
like I don't know what I did yeah I
don't know what happened in Malta all I
remember is that everyone was really
like you couldn't negotiate a lot on
things oh yeah yeah and that's where you
get the game boys with all the games
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly [ __ ] yeah
yeah I remember it's a Bulgaria as a kid
and that was very much like a this is
the price unless you can like haggle
with me yeah and yeah you could get
games that were like definitely not real
games
the Game Boy cartridges that had like a
hundred one thousand games one thousand
games in one cartridge I remember this
is back on DVDs like piracy was like
huge and you could just get like 20
billion DVDs for like one Euro oh it was
like Bulgaria and they were just like we
have nothing else to do take take 20
DVDs be like Spider-Man but only with
Bulgarian subtitles you know like well
it was it was 20 cents so uh what can
you do
all those pirated games were so [ __ ] too
oh they were so bad of course yeah yeah
yeah like I I remember like you because
all of the 101 pirated games you'd never
heard of any of these games yeah and I'm
just like what is what is this game I've
never heard of it I've seen the hundred
thousand in one okay I've not seen that
those are good it's like 80 games and
they start looping oh yeah oh that's
good yeah those are good and out of the
80 games it's like 30 of them are just
snake but re-skinned yeah yeah true
snake was a good game yeah it was a good
game but like they would they would
purposely like name a different things
like super snake oh like Cobra do you
still gain much or is it not really that
much anymore uh uh I'm sure it's more on
like a casual sense right or you call me
casual yeah
are you a normal gamer now Felix
I don't like to say it because I'm so
bad at Japanese still but I'm trying to
focus on that right now right okay yeah
I'm not a gamer right now I'm just
focusing on Japanese honestly yeah I'm
trying to I mean it makes sense how
about if you play the game in Japanese
yeah I've done that
how did I go
switched it back right away
which which game did you try to play I
did them for Valerian actually it was
kind of bad because the voice actors
changed it's kind of cool are you a
Valor player uh I did well Jack got me
into it oh and I also got really into it
and then he [ __ ] stopped playing I'm
like this [ __ ] he's like I have
now pushed the blame yeah
just sitting alone in lobbies with fives
[ __ ] strangers yelling at each other
I'm like why am I doing this this is
[ __ ] torture why am I playing this
are you playing much on the Japanese
servers or anything like that that's a
pretty good way to learn oh yeah it did
play a little bit of magic that was like
my introduction to Japanese Gamers
because they're so [ __ ] passive
aggressive oh yeah oh yeah bro they
don't all the emotes all the time I'm
like bro I haven't even done anything
yet I keep saying good game to me chill
they refuse to use mics a lot of the
time you have to like drag them onto the
mic they just won't like even in like
OverWatch or uh Apex Legends like
dangerous team yeah and everyone's like
in America you would just talk
immediately but in Japan it's like you
really have to like pry it out of them
but sometimes they're really funny and
they're really impossible to do they're
a lot more confident online real life is
right it is a different anniversary yeah
good way to try and practice
yeah but like you know it's it's you're
learning you're probably learning some
words outside of the Apex game oh God
yeah yeah that you shouldn't use outside
wait you said it in real life you'll be
like oh God where'd you learn it's like
a good way to learn just what are some
like Japanese gamer terms it's oh I
forgot there was one there was one that
meant like swamp and it was when you
couldn't stop gacha pulling yeah means
like we're stuck in this one basically
when you're addicted yeah okay yeah that
was a good one um so it's like when
you're addicted to something you'd say
you're in a sportsman you can't get out
there are some fun ones I think English
is way better gaming terms yeah I think
we had much more fun terms I don't know
when they're when they were explaining
it to me
I don't know just I don't know not like
because like I mean I think English has
better slang in general and obviously it
just translates to gaming terms as well
so yeah I mean I miss gaming with you
know English-speaking people sometimes
because
like I notice as well Japanese people
are very passive aggressive and they
never get too involved but when they do
I don't know sometimes the passive
aggressive emotes they uh they trigger
me more than if someone just tells just
gets angry at work you know yeah I've
shut up some Japanese Gamers leave the
game over like the smallest thing it's
just so bizarre if you don't if you like
take an item they wanted they'll just
immediately leave they're like [ __ ] this
yeah that's a dick move yeah damn maybe
I shouldn't took it but [ __ ] them
you're a need roller yeah I mean come on
man that's when you do the emote yeah
yeah have you tried watching anime
without subtitles in uh I feel like it
helps with the subtitles though like in
general earlier on earlier on it earlier
on yeah okay oh sorry I watched English
sometimes like I don't know what the
[ __ ] they're saying I need subtitles I'm
eating I can't [ __ ] hear do you watch
much anime since coming here yeah I'm
watching One Piece right now it's so
good hell yeah hell yeah nice it's
really good so simony or something
absolutely
that's a giant Island oh giant Island
okay oh dinosaurs and [ __ ] yeah yeah
it's really yeah that's why I just got
up to reading oh really I'm just past
that same part yeah we are we are all
right yeah
it is yeah I like it oh yeah we started
a really funny one but I don't remember
the name it's a recent one oh uh I think
there's only one housewife yaxa or
something oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
wave of the house
it's on Netflix it's like [ __ ] animation
it looks like a manga it's like a
PowerPoint yeah I like that though yeah
I mean it's funnier in some ways yeah
and the timing is so good the way they
do it yeah the acting in Japanese is on
point yeah yeah that's really good I
haven't watched English but I just with
the Japanese one they were amazing it's
like a lot of people complain about that
adaptation when it came out because oh
really yeah the animation
has like a hardcore fan base yeah
Sakamoto and if you like that it's oh
yeah it's like that well animated and
funny yeah I think it's funny oh really
because I thought it was hilarious so
yeah you'll love it you'll love it it's
great yeah cool did you watch it like
just pure subtitles in Japanese or did
you I'm not that Jersey all right
well I often find that actually I I like
at the beginning I tried to start doing
that and I was like this is not helping
at all but then I watched like enough
and I'm like [ __ ] I'm starting to like
pick [ __ ] up now because all right kind
of like forces your ears to like I need
to force my ears yeah yeah yeah yeah
because with the subtitles there you
just like you subconsciously you just
ignore what they're that what they're
saying yeah it just like turns into
white noise after a while if you're just
focusing on the subtitles but like if
you don't have anything there then
you're just like oh I know what that
word is so I can kind of draw context
from it yeah yeah don't get that that
does happen very rarely
unfortunately yeah getting there man I I
watched Netflix with Japanese subtitles
on but I watch it in English I don't
know why I just I've put it on I've just
left it I've just left it on oh okay can
you read it fast enough though no but
sometimes I I can read some of the kanji
so it's it's nice to like practice just
reading it but also sometimes you see
candies that pop up all the time and
you're like oh like if you see the kinds
of it you don't know what it means then
yeah I know exactly it's like well I
know what it means but I don't know how
to say it's just reading practice a
little bit for stuff I do know but I I
didn't I don't know why I put it on I
just never turned it off and I'm like
because it doesn't really matter to like
click yeah I realize I feel like I
watched the weirdest [ __ ] at the gym
because everyone in the gym I feel like
50 of the time they're watching yeah if
I'm on the treadmill oh okay if I'm if
I'm like what if you're like doing a
chat right I just put the thing on the
floor really listen to it okay this is
like the Netflix documentary oh what
that's so weird I can't do that yeah
because like if I'm if I'm focused yeah
I can't focus on the content no because
that's really focused I'm too tired
because I feel like I get when I get
super into the show the gym set comes
like it becomes so easy it just flows
especially for running and cycling oh no
that I get no running a cycling I
understand but like if you're doing reps
and stuff so I'll do the running
watching the documentary I'm like well I
gotta keep watching
I have to go into the gym and I have to
make sure that the people on treadmills
aren't watching One Piece because all of
them are watching One Piece oh really
and I'm like I don't want to get spoiled
uh so when I'm running on the treadmill
and I see they're watching One Piece I
have to like I can't like [ __ ] why don't
you watch One Piece as well be part of
the team because because I can I I could
see because I could see Lou foreign
[Applause]
I know it's like seven billion episodes
away but I'm like I just I just saw it
and now I'm gonna think about it all the
time and I'm gonna wait till Luffy songs
get [ __ ] up for some reason I don't
know what's happening why is it look
like that I don't know I'm gonna figure
out the whole time forget about
something about it let it leave your
brain yeah no to me if I like try to
watch something in the gym or while I'm
doing exercise I will like I've tried
that before and I've watched entire
things I finished my set I'm like I have
no idea what I just watched oh yeah
exits
I think I watched an episode of my hero
yeah that's why that's why I put the BTO
content for the gym uh it's like I'm not
I'm not watching like breaking badge or
any of the best TV shows it's like I'll
put the stuff that I'm like I'll watch
but
yeah in the gym AKA Netflix
documentaries which are all the [ __ ]
same and it's just like he was a good
boy until he wasn't and then he killed
everything documentaries are so [ __ ]
bad I'm giving up completely
yeah every now and then there's a
semi-good one yeah but I'm it's not
worth it no I agree I agree yeah there
was like way too many episodes too they
they do drag things out a lot more than
I need to and they I swear to God all
these production companies have like
agreed on a format because they're all
the same yeah exactly they're shot the
same they're lit the same the way that
they structure interviews and stuff is
all the same no they just kind of just
reverse engineer what Netflix expects
and they know they like so they're just
like well if that documentation like
five years ago the exact same way five
years ago it's really new and refreshing
and it was cool it was well these
documentaries are so cool no one talked
about True Crime on and then yeah and
now everyone everyone on YouTube
everyone on Netflix